they were risking arrest by gathering in
Berlin to commemorate not by day and it
wasn't long before police intervened and
started questioning them Germany has a
large population of Palestinians but
they say their rights to express
themselves have increasingly been
curtailed it's like they're always the
excuse what Israel is making crimes
against humanity just talking about the
sensitivity of Germany and the guilt of
Germany I do understand this and my
heart goes out for the Holocaust victims
and the survivors but this should not be
a reason to prosecute other people after
a brief discussion police allowed a
commemoration to continue it has become
increasingly difficult for Palestinians
to protest here in Germany now anger is
growing about the developments in Israel
German authorities are increasingly
clamping down on demonstrations here
saying they could turn anti-semitic a
sensitive issue here in Germany since
the Holocaust of the Nazis last year
dozens of protesters were detained by
police on Knock by day it was the first
time the demonstration was banned after
many years of Palestinian protests in
Germany in 2019 the German Parliament
adopted a resolution calling a
Palestinian pressure group anti-semitic
the government's commissioner for Jewish
Affairs has anti-Semitism is on the rise
with 96 percent of incidents committed
by far-right groups and the rest
attributed to Palestinian protesters
everyone is allowed to protest against
Israeli policies but the limit is when
it becomes anti-semitic when the
existence of Israel is being disputed or
when the actions of the Israeli Army are
being compared to what the Nazis did
during World War II
police tell us that because of increased
tensions between Israel and Palestine
emotions of Palestinians in Germany are
running high and their actions risk
breaking the law
Palestinians say it's an affront to
their constitutional rights this
constitutional right and
law has been flipped around by the court
and the Berlin Police
and this is something that is a danger
for the Democracy itself
[Music]
lawyers have challenged the bans in
court but so far judges have sided with
the police step fast and Al Jazeera in
Berlin